semaine décisive pour le projet de loi
sur l'extension du pass sanitaire validé
sous conditions par le conseil d'état la
dernière version du texte arrivera en
commission à l'assemblée nationale dès
demain les députés examineront le texte
et auditionneront les ministres avant un
débat qui s'annonce houleux dans
l'hémicycle en cause des mesures jugées
liberticides par certains les précisions
de notre reporter guilmard aussi bonsoir
guilmain gabriela talent a dévoilé la
dernière version de ce projet de loi en
sait-on plus sur ce texte qui sera on
sert largement débattu durant les
prochains jours au sein de l'hémicycle
eh bien oui david de l'écouter il y a
tout d'abord ce qui ne change pas c'est
à dire l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants 15 septembre ou encore
l'extension des restrictions au barreau
gare ou encore au restaurant et puis il
y a ceux qui a d'ores et déjà été
modifié dans ce texte notamment les
sanctions
on ne parle plus par exemple de la deûle
amende de 45000 euros pour les
établissements qui ne contrôleraient pas
le passé ni terme et seulement 2000
euros pour une première infraction à
noter également david que le conseil
d'état vient de retoquer l'obligation de
contrôle du passo sanitaires pour les
grands centres commerciaux la haute
juridiction administrative qui a en
revanche validé l'obligation d'isolement
de dix jours pour les personnes
positives au covin 19
alors ce texte il doit être désormais
adoptée par le parlement c'est une
procédure est clair qu'il va s'engager
demain à l'assemblée nationale le texte
sera adopté sont quelques jours une
semaine tout au plus et donc devrait
entrer en vigueur au début du mois
d'août sauf que sauf si le conseil
constitutionnel est saisi comme ont
prévu de le faire déjà plusieurs groupes
parlementaires et dans ce cas vu
les délais bien ce fameux pass sanitaire
pourrait n'entrer en application le cas
la fin de l'été merci beaucoup il marre
aussi en direct depuis l'elysée